all right let's get into um audience
questions for the week and the last set
of audience questions of 2020
very exciting okay first question david
we hear all the bluster from trump
special counsel martial law he won
lawsuits all of this other stuff is
trump genuinely
going to try to physically stay in the
white house after january 20th i think
the answer is still no
i think the answer is still no um i know
that there we reported on trump
floating or suggesting to some uh
some of his aides maybe i just won't
leave
sort of thing i think that donald trump
either already knows or will become
convinced
by the time january 20th rolls around uh
that it would be really really
embarrassing for himself
to you know have to be escorted out of
the white house or for reports to be
that he was
refusing to leave or something like that
now the truth is
he probably has some followers that are
so sycophantic
that if trump tried it they would see it
as some kind of act of defiant heroism
rather than the corrosive act for the
country that that it would be
um but but i do believe that you know
trump's kids i think would all get it
like you can't physically try to stay it
would be humiliating to try to do it
um i don't think he's actually going to
try to do it now between now and then
he will continue in 61 he will continue
to tweet the things he's been tweeting
and look at
could could i maybe get this overturned
in some way
but even donald trump i am sure
recognizes
that just staying there absent
any court decision about you know not
accepting results or
these things are all going by the
wayside every time we reach a new
milestone
in the process of certifying and
electors voting and all of that um
i i think even trump recognizes absent
something tangible to say look this
state has flipped now or
something i don't think he's going to
physically try to do it now
i i admit that as someone who covers
this stuff
uh trump talks about ratings i can
imagine no greater ratings
than video of donald trump being
forcibly removed from the white house
but
i don't believe it will happen it would
be absolutely terrible
terrible for for the country i believe
really the milestone date for trump will
be january 6th
um i think on uh on on january 6th
mike pence is planning after the
official counting
of the electoral votes which have
already been cast remember january 6th
is just the formalization of
a joint session of the house and senate
counting those votes
mike pence is scheduled to within hours
leave the country and go on a trip to
i think it's poland and maybe uh uae i
don't remember exactly the countries
and i would not be surprised if trump is
even still in washington by then
there's rumors he may be leaving sooner
um
for trump to completely disappear and
maybe even abandon the white house i
don't know
there's the idea he'll stay in the white
house and then fly to a rally on
inauguration day there's the idea he'll
never return from christmas
and just stay in florida there's the
idea that january 6 maybe when he sort
of formally
gives it up and and we stop hearing from
him altogether
uh but i believe that he is not if if
the question is will trump
tr try and consider any mechanism or
manipulation
that might allow him to steal the
election the answer is of course yes and
he's thought of everything um
lawsuits of different kinds trying to
send different electors convincing state
legislatures and governors to send
different electors that came and went
um seizing voting machines which is
some of his lawyers told him you can't
do a martial law was reportedly flown
you know all of these different ideas he
he's
morally willing to do any of it but i do
not believe he will
physically try to stay in the oval
office
no